hey guys i think it's time to give
ordinary people a tax break
why do i quit it's called a tax break
joe biden
doesn't just have a senior moment or two
it's like every time he talks
and it seems to be getting worse joe
biden was
addressing reporters the other day it's
a rare occurrence when biden addresses
reporters
and he forgot to address this issue of
the building collapse he just seemed to
forget what had happened and
so this was a really bad thing i haven't
covered it too much on the show
because it's just sad i don't think
there's too much of a political angle
here it's just like a really really sad
thing
and so joe biden was supposed to talk
about this he forgot to so kamala harris
had to remind him
i've got to get helicopters
will you travel to florida sir can we
ask you about florida what you've
learned
oh yes i apologize yes thank you my
president
uh i've spoken with coincidentally
the mayor of miami-dade
was in my office yesterday and i talked
to her today
not about that obviously and so i had a
long discussion with her today
i've also spoken with we've come in
contact with the congresswoman
debbie wasserman schultz who has that
district this does remind me of a moment
the very very end of of reagan's tenure
there was a moment where he seemed to
forget what he was
saying or what what he was talking about
and there you can see it on video
nancy kind of subtly turns to him and
just says doing the best we can
and then reagan you know great great
orator great performance
well we're doing the best we can well i
and it was the moment where people
started to say gosh is he
did he have a senior moment now
revisionists have gone back and said oh
yeah reagan was
just absolutely in the throes of
alzheimer's during his whole presidency
that's preposterous ronald reagan ended
the cold war during his presidency he
was extremely sharp
for virtually all of his presidency he
was at that time the oldest
guy ever elected president and maybe he
had a senior moment or two
no question joe biden
doesn't just have a senior moment or two
it's not just one moment where he kind
of goes a little absent-minded well
we're doing
it's it's like every time he talks and
it seems to be getting worse
and it's a lot different ronald reagan
is giving some impromptu remarks versus
joe biden at a formal press conference
and the vice president needs to tell him
what's going on he's been
he's got a lot of quirks lately you've
seen he's he's also fallen into another
very strange rhetorical trap where he
starts
to emphasize something by by an
exaggerated stage whisper he just did
this the other day talking about
taxes and people say well that's a
giveaway
hey guys i think it's time to give
ordinary people a tax break
the wealthy are doing fine i mean it
i mean it why is this
not a tax break for working folks
when the stuff we give to the super
wealthy are called tax breaks
oh okay so that was weird it's weird
when he doesn't he leans and goes hey
he's got his weird creepy biden eyes
popping out of his head we hey
why do i quits called a tax break so but
he
recovered there was it sort of worked
well enough sometimes it hasn't worked
well just the other day he was also
speaking to reporters and he he
whispered a little too hard a little too
long
i wrote the bill on the environment
why would i not be for it
[Applause]
it's that that was not not quite as
effective as when he was talking about
the taxes now i point all this out
the senior moment the weird whispering
stuff that losing his train of thought
because i i'm not just trying to make
fun of him it's perfectly fine to have a
laugh at old joe's expense
but it's because regardless of all that
he's very effective he is and we just
we we mock him or we dismiss him at our
own peril
the guy is very effective he's survived
in politics
for 50 years he has been at the top
levels of american politics
for half a century he beat out
a lot of other democrats this go around
who were much younger
and more impressive than he is he's
very effective and his those these
senior moments and this apparent
incompetence
i think is in some ways a helpful
distraction
for the liberal establishment that acts
through him because he just gives them
whatever they want he basically walked
into the white house
and he said okay state department here's
here's the keys to foreign policy
okay liberal establishment here are the
keys to whatever economic policy or
trade and he just said i'm going to be
watching matlock over in the corner
and that's very very effective that's
why we've now
all the gains we had made in the middle
east gone the gains we had made
negotiating with china gone
joe's a huge fan of china joe has
famously said
repeatedly that it's good for the united
states for china to get bigger and
stronger and richer
i don't think that's true i think china
is our number one enemy
but the liberal establishment love
that's why they let china into the world
trade organization that's why they
refuse to blame china for the
coronavirus that's why they've helped
china cover up
their creation of the coronavirus and
they're
in their own cover-up of the coronavirus
and
american corporations are helping out
too but as i said this is why i don't
just say
the government i don't just talk about
big government i talk about the liberal
establishment because that includes
the universities the elected government
the administrative government
big tech and lower education
and woke corporations hold up
glad you liked that video go check out
the whole episode it's right here it's
called pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain you can also get it
on apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play all the places
for your audio podcast and most
importantly of all
after you like and subscribe and leave
comment you can go order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
it's the number one book in civil rights
right now i am the number one civil
rights leader in the country
go check it out i'll see you next time